[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur ce
plateau celui de face au territoire sur
TV5 Monde vous savez diffuser dans 200
pays et en 14 langues avec nos
partenaires coproducteurs de cette
émission Ouest-France vous pouvez
d'ailleurs nous regarder sur
ouest-france.fr sur nice-matin.com par
contre sur France anti.fr sur la
montagne.fr et sur 20 minutes.fr qui
sont donc les partenaires coproducteurs
de cette émission mon invité ce matin
c'est Jean Josel bonjour merci d'être
avec nous Jean Josel merci vous êtes
climatologue vous êtes L'Express
vice-président du GIEC groupe d'études
d'experts intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat et puis vous
publiez un livre parlons vrai avec
Baptiste Denis et votre dernier livre
aux éditions Les pérégrines évidemment
nous allons parler du climat évidence
j'allais dire nous allons en parler
parce que on en a très peu parlé durant
cette campagne présidentielle pourquoi
comment expliquer vous que ce sujet du
réchauffement climatique n'est pas été
présent dans les débats que les
candidats ne s'en soit pas saisis oui
c'était l'espoir effectivement
deux des rapports du GIEC ont été
adoptés pendant la campagne électorale
française c'est un hasard du calendrier
le rapport sur les conséquences du
réchauffement climatique le 28 février
celui sur les solutions à mettre en
œuvre et bien le 4 avril et en fait ça
fait un flop bon probablement parce que
l'actualité des tournées vers plutôt
vers l'Est plutôt vers autre chose mais
c'est une des un des problèmes du
réchauffement climatique c'est une
priorité mais il y a toujours une autre
priorité qui pense à place des
rencontres bien aussi ce n'est pas le
problème la pandémie la guerre en
Ukraine tout cela c'est très important
mais il y a vraiment urgence peut-on
totalement évacuer le fait que le
réchauffement climatique de la terre
soit issue d'un cycle naturel on peut le
dire oui sur Oui c'est un des résultats
principaux je dirais du dernier rapport
du GIEC on passe dans le domaine des
certitudes sans équivoque le
réchauffement climatique est lié aux
activités même les mêmes la meilleure
façon de l'expliquer on a un peu plus de
1 degré mais on l'explique entièrement
par nos activités donc le réchauffement
climatique ce sont vraiment nos
activités les visant les causes
naturelles du climat qui sont bien là ne
peuvent expliquer sur le dernier siècle
qu'un dixième de degrés ils ont le
réchauffement de plus d'un degré ce sont
nos activités de façon certaine ces gens
je vous aime qui est avec nous le
climatologue et nous allons évidemment
parler tout au long de cette émission en
direct des problématiques liées à
l'environnement dans un instant voici
François-Xavier lefranc-le-rédacteur
chef de Ouest-France
bonjour François-Xavier Lefranc vous
avez la particularité avec notre
issu de la même région la Bretagne
effectivement la Bretagne vive la
Bretagne bonjour connaissons bien avec
François-Xavier bonjour bonjour Je vous
aime vous êtes à porte-parole
infatigable de la cause du climat vous
êtes un grand scientifique reconnu au
niveau international on peut le dire
vous êtes aussi breton on vient de le
dire vous êtes né dans une famille
d'agriculteurs du Pays de Rennes à Janzé
très exactement est-ce que cette
proximité avec le monde rural avec la
nature à compter dans votre engagement à
la fois votre engagement professionnel
et votre engagement aujourd'hui pour le
climat alors mon engagement
professionnel je dirais qu'il est quand
même plus il s'est construit autour de
la recherche autour de la recherche sur
l'évolution des climats du passé donc
j'ai travaillé sur des au départ dans
les années 70 sur
comment peut-on reconstruire les Paris
sans climatiques du passé à partir des
glaces polaires avec des collègues comme
Claude Lorius beaucoup d'autres mais ce
sont c'est vraiment la recherche qui m'a
conduit à me poser des questions sur le
rôle des activités humaines mais c'est
vrai qu'après et bien je suis
extrêmement proche effectivement
disons de cette nature de la Bretagne
j'ai vécu j'y suis né mon frère et
toujours mon frère mon neveu sont
toujours agriculteurs donc ce monde je
le connais bien et ça me permet
effectivement de rester très proche de
ce qui est l'émission aujourd'hui des
territoires Givors régulen nous y allons
régulièrement et ça a joué un rôle même
si pas l'élément déclencheur de disons
de je dirais de mon regard sur
l'évolution du climat c'est quand même
plus un regard de scientifique au départ
est-ce qu'il y a des climatosceptiques
dans votre famille oui voilà bon c'est
vrai mais enfin j'ai mon frère est né un
an plus que moi jour pour jour il a
quand même un peu évolué disons je
dirais qu'il était vraiment
climato-sceptique maintenant il laisse
un peu de place au doute dans le bon
sens je veux dire qu'il se pose quand
même une bonne question vous évoquiez
tout à l'heure Claude Lorius et avec
l'eau de glorius en 2002 vous avez
obtenu la plus grande récompense
scientifique française la médaille d'or
du CNRS pour des travaux sur les
calottes glaciaires que vous avez
analysé pour comprendre l'évolution du
climat à partir de quel moment avez-vous
eu le sentiment qu'il se passait quelque
chose
le tournant pour nous c'est l'année 87
en fait c'est là et on doit leur rendre
hommage des chercheurs soviétiques sont
à vos stock le point le plus froid du
globe ce sont les premiers à
au-delà de 2 km et
disons une carotte de glace qui couvre
plus de 150 000 ans et en fait il nous
l'offre grâce à Claude glorius Claude
laurious obtient ces échantillons nous
analysons en France de notre côté à
saclaine ou reconstruisons la
température les variations du climat et
mes collègues grenoblois Dominique
Raynaud enfin l'équipe de Claude Lorius
Jean-Marc barnola à l'époque
reconstruisent les variations de teneur
en gaz carbonique et puis en méthane
pour Jérôme chaplazella on voit
effectivement pour la première fois on
parlait beaucoup d'effet de serre mais
c'était un peu énigmatique on a parlé à
travers Mars et Vénus qui avait des
climats différents parce que leur
atmosphère est différente ou bien de
façon théorique mais le voir de
visualisons vraiment de façon
extrêmement
ça saute aux yeux quand on regarde les
couilles les courbes ce lien entre il y
a moins d'effets de serre il fait plus
froid il y a aussi d'autres raisons ce
n'est pas cela mais disons ça
effectivement
eu une importance extrêmement très
rapidement d'ailleurs par exemple c'est
emparé de ses courbes très rapidement et
disons ça le
l'alerte n'est pas sonnée par par n'est
pas donné à traverser ces résultats et
les donner à travers les résultats des
modélisateurs du climat dont d'ailleurs
sous qui Manabe a été reconnu puisqu'il
y a eu prix Nobel de physique l'an
dernier mais ça a ajouté évidemment la
perception et là vraiment c'est la
perception de la réalité de du lien
entre climat et effet de serre qui est
alors nous saute aux yeux vous avez mené
des études scientifiques extrêmement
poussées qui ont permis de d'établir la
vérité des faits et puis ensuite il y a
un deuxième combat qu'il a fallu mener
c'est celui de convaincre de faire
comprendre faire comprendre notamment
aux décideurs aux responsables
politiques et là on a l'impression que
c'est un combat extrêmement difficile on
en parlait tout à l'heure cette prise de
conscience qui met du temps alors que le
climat lui continue à changer oui alors
on peut on peut vraiment disons pendant
je dirais que l'alerte sonner dans les
80 d'ailleurs le GIEC se met en place en
8 premier rapport en 90 le Sommet de la
Terre en 92 mais dans les années 90 et
bien c'est quand même un peu il y a pas
beaucoup d'intérêt pour ce réchauffement
climatique les par exemple les grandes
entreprises ne s'y intéressent pas il y
a même un lobbying de ça bien maintenant
documenté des grandes compagnies
pétrolières pour disons mettre ces
alerte des scientifiques sous le
boisseau et puis dans les années 2000 et
bien c'est vraiment la période du
scepticisme
les il y a ce qu'on appelle le plateau
c'est-à-dire que le réchauffement
ralenti au cours des années 2000 et ça
atteint son summum d'une certaine façon
justement de la conférence de Copenhague
en 2009 avec ce qu'on a appelé climate
Gates c'est-à-dire bon il y a eu la
subtilité enfin disons certains alors
mais ils ont été subtilisés du GIEC et
ça a été une période assez difficile oui
alors à la pointe de la mobilisation
aujourd'hui il y a les jeunes et jeunes
générations partout dans le monde
comment est-ce que vous expliquez que
les générations les plus anciennes
semble si peu prendre conscience de ce
qui se passe il faut que ce soit les
jeunes qui aujourd'hui poussent les
politiques à agir ils sont à vos côtés
ces jeunes y compris électoralement
français
d'abord parce que son doublement
concernées ils sont concernés à la fois
par
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique c'est aujourd'hui les jeunes
qui vont rentrer dans le disons je
dirais dans le monde du travail vont
participer je l'espère à cette lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique mais
ce sont eux aussi qui sont
malheureusement concernés par les
conséquences majeures du réchauffement
climatique les conséquences majeures du
réchauffement climatique c'est dans la
deuxième partie de ce siècle et au-delà
ce sont les jeunes d'aujourd'hui ce ne
sont pas les générations futures mais ce
sont eux qui sont concernés au premier
chef ceci étant c'est un excuse pas du
tout bien sûr le manque de prise de
conscience de alors de nos générations
je dirais il y a quand même eu une prise
de conscience de certains décideurs
politiques au cours des 30 dernières
années mais la réalité alors que dès 90
nous savions qu'il fallait diminuer nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre c'est
qu'elles ont doublé par exemple entre
1970 et aujourd'hui donc voilà on a on
est quand même disons d'un côté il y a
un constat je dirais un message très
clair de la communauté scientifique il
faut diminuer les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre de l'autre ces émissions
n'ont pas arrêté d'augmenter sauf disons
de façon je dirais très ponctuelle
qu'est-ce que vous diriez à ces jeunes
qu'on voit là des défilés qu'est-ce que
vous diriez à ces jeunes qui sont à vos
côtés je le répète qu'est-ce que vous
leur diriez de continuer à se mobiliser
c'est important cette mobilité c'est
très important j'ai fait beaucoup
démarches sur le climat au côté des
jeunes effectivement donc je je cet
engagement a été extrêmement important
il a été extrêmement important par
exemple pour la prise en compte de la
formation la transition écologique dans
dans l'enseignement je dirais que c'est
grâce à la mobilisation des jeunes des
lycéens mais aussi bien sûr des univers
des disons des étudiants dans le
supérieur ils sont sans mobilisés et par
exemple et bien la madame la ministre
m'a demandé à nous a demandé de nous
l'avons fait disons de réfléchir à aux
mesures qui pourraient être prises pour
lui disons dans le domaine de
l'enseignement supérieur et c'est grâce
aux jeunes que c'est disons disons cette
prise de conscience de nos dirigeants a
été vraiment effective alors on parle
déjà donc pour aussi parler des médias
il est important que les médias portent
aussi ce sujet là oui et je tiens à
remercier Ouest-France puisque bon je
suis effectivement je suis la presse
régionale qui prend très souvent en
compte bien sûr ces aspects climatiques
je suis très souvent appelé aussi par
Nice-Matin sur pour témoigner de la
réalité du réchauffement c'est c'est
vraiment important les politiques qui à
vos yeux ont le mieux réussi dans cette
dans ce système d'alerte que que vous
souhaitez voir arriver encore plus fort
alors d'un côté
enfin bon moi j'ai eu la chance de de
côtoyer de plus Jacques Chirac tous les
présidents de la République enfin disons
qui a été vraiment
important sur ces questions là je dirais
Jacques Chirac c'est la maison brûle ce
n'est que le Sarkozy c'est c'est
vraiment le grand de l'environnement
disons que franchement
c'est de l'accord de Paris al gorge a
joué un rôle très important au niveau
international et c'est vraiment le fait
qu'il n'ait pas été élu en 2000 et que
ce soit Georges Bush qui était élu sa
disons ça le fait que les États-Unis ne
s'intègrent pas dans le dans l'accord de
Paris a été extrêmement négatif donc
effectivement Emmanuel Macron il y a
aussi une action mais j'ai été
extrêmement déçu je l'ai dit par disons
ça reprise en compte des propositions
des citoyens alors vous le connaissez
connu qui est un collaborateur et
dessinateur de Ouest-France à une
question à vous poser c'est un peu la
tradition de cette émission voilà sous
forme de dessin on regarde où est-ce
qu'on regarde
les Bretons ont la tête dure et vous
n'avez jamais changé d'avis sur le
réchauffement climatique en 1912 le
Titanic sombré après avoir percuté
aniceberg en 2022 notre planète se
dirige tout droit tel le Titanic vers
une catastrophe la question que je pose
est bien entendu en rapport avec la
crise énergétique liée à la guerre en
Ukraine pourquoi l'Allemagne grand pays
de l'écologie politique a-t-elle décidé
de fermer ces centrales nucléaires au
profit des centrales à charbon le
charbon énorme contributeurs au rejet de
CO2 dans l'atmosphère
pour conclure faut-il s'en réjouir et
bien les républicains les socialistes et
les écologistes français sont eux entrés
dans une aire glaciaire voilà donc merci
je n'ai merci de votre question le
pourquoi effectivement quand on regarde
la politique allemande au cours des 20
dernières années c'est l'énergie Vanden
donc vraiment il y a eu une politique de
disons de sortir du nucléaire
tout simplement enfin il y a c'est quand
même des accidents disons nucléaire le
Fukishima par exemple ils ont vraiment
contribué à une prise de conscience sur
mobile Fukushima et donc c'est peut-être
ça qui est aussi disons qui est dans
l'esprit des Allemands extrêmement
négatif par rapport au nucléaire ceci
étant évidemment le nucléaire et le
renouvelable sont les moyens de lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique de
produire de l'énergie sans émission de
gaz à effet de serre la Une de
Ouest-France François-Xavier Lefrançois
va vous faire la guerre est aux portes
de l'Europe la solidarité européenne à
faire sérieuse et là ça ne rigole pas et
il y a bien deux visions diamétralement
opposées
dans le ces élections présidentielles en
France Merci François-Xavier Lefranc
vous êtes le rédacteur en chef 2
Ouest-France le plus grand journal
francophone du monde merci à vous dans
un instant Denis Caro de Nice-Matin sur
ce plateau
voilà et ces gens je vous aime le
climatologue ex vice-président du GIEC
qui est notre invité ce matin dans face
au territoire
Denis carro avant que nous interviewions
ensemble genre je vous aime Joseph à
Raquel qui est engagé dans
l'entrepreneuriat qui est un chef
d'entreprise marseillais
l'entrepreneuriat social et écologique
donc à Marseille à une question à vous
poser on l'écoute
nous travaillons avec la métropole de
Marseille représentée par Martine vassal
sur un projet de recyclerie de proximité
qui aura pour objectif de récompenser
les personnes qui apporteront des
déchets sur ses points gérer par du
personnel en insertion afin de faire un
tri à la source et déchets qui sont un
gisement de valeur seront triés par
nature afin d'éviter l'enfouissement ou
l'incinération ne pensez-vous pas que ce
laboratoire pourrait être transposé sur
d'autres territoires
du social à l'écologie ou vice-versa oui
c'est très important les déchets jouent
un rôle évidemment dans le cycle
énergétique de de quelques pourcent de
5% de la production d'énergie mais il y
a aussi la récupération de beaucoup de
matériaux qui sont extrêmement utiles
disons le recyclage est vraiment au cœur
oui je dirais d'une certaine sobriété de
nos économies ça c'est très important et
oui j'encourage effectivement disons des
expériences du type de celles que nous
que vous mentionnez disons à échelle le
plus large possible au niveau de notre
territoire et au-delà bien sûr Denis
carreau Georges nozel le GIEC dresse des
constats dessine des solutions mais les
choses bougent peu et on a l'impression
que le climat est une priorité qui passe
toujours après d'autres priorités
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait faire qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire pour agir vraiment
alors pour agir vraiment nous savons ce
qu'il faut faire effectivement puisque
les états nous le disent l'accord de
Paris nous dit qu'il faut diminuer les
émissions nous savons par exemple en
France quels sont
disons les secteurs 30% pour le
transport 20% pour ou un peu moins pour
l'énergie pour l'agriculture
alimentation agriculture pour
l'urbanisme l'urbanisme donc on sait
effectivement que bien isoler les
bâtiments par exemple est extrêmement à
moyen terme extrêmement porteur tout le
problème de la mobilité douce des
transports en commun de une certaine
sobriété dans notre mobilité est aussi
devrait être aussi être au rendez-vous
donc nous savons ce qu'il faut faire
bien sûr on a un peu évoqué la
production d'énergie il y a ce rapport
de RTE qui est important il y a des
décisions qui vont être prises et qu'on
était pratiquement prises par rapport à
la relance de l'énergie nucléaire mais
tout cela est bien c'est important
d'avoir une énergie sans émotion de gaz
à effet de serre cette neutralité
carbone en 7 c'est inscrit dans la loi
la neutralité carbone elle est inscrite
dans la loi mais comment il va-t-on
réellement nous prenons du retard dans
notre pays c'est bien ça le problème et
voilà donc comment fait-on pour que
effectivement la réalité en France soit
en face avec la feuille de route qui est
inscrite dans la loi alors on voit qu'il
y a beaucoup de mobilisation la semaine
dernière encore il y avait des défilés
des manifestations est-ce que la rue
est-ce que l'opinion peut peser
davantage ça fait partie l'opinion me
semble-t-il on a bien sûr à travers les
jeunes à travers les marches pour le
climat disons de c'est nécessaire de que
que les gens
se mobilise pour la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique l'adaptation
mais c'est aussi disons on voit bien la
réalité puisque disons l'état un rôle à
jouer il y a une loi et j'aurais aimé
que et bien la tête loi tienne mieux en
compte plus en compte les propositions
les territoires ont un rôle extrêmement
important à jouer quand on regarde la
mobilité le bâtiment l'urbanisme c'est
au niveau local régional que ça se passe
est-ce que justement c'est pas là le bon
échelon on voit qu'il y a des
collectivités qui multiplient les
initiatives il y a plein de choses
intéressantes qui se font partout en
France est-ce que c'est pas là que
concrètement on peut agir le plus je le
pense parce que pour ce qui concerne je
dirais bâtiment urbanisme développement
des énergies renouvelables et quand je
vais disons en région PACA je regrette
toujours que le solaire n'est pas la
place qu'il y mérite soyons clairs vous
ne voyez pas Marseille comme une ville
exemplaire de ce point-là encore non ça
viendra peut-être mais bon disons il
faut vraiment il y a vraiment du retard
par rapport disons à l'utilisation du
solaire dans une région où il était sans
le soleil est quand même extrêmement
présent un peu plus qu'en Bretagne on
nous parlions tout à l'heure mais voilà
donc il y a des possibilités donc c'est
au niveau des territoires que cela se
passe effectivement quand on parle de
mobilité quand on parle
comment conçoit-on les villes du futur
c'est villes vont se développer avec des
risques aussi liés à la dissonance
certaines régions depuis des mois
l'élévation du niveau de la mer il faut
être aussi très prudent il y a une
nécessité d'adaptation et une cité de
prévention et tout ça c'est au niveau
des territoires de Nico est-ce que
l'Europe a rôle à jouer en matière de
climat on voit que
l'Europe est capable de parler d'une
même voix on le voit avec la guerre en
Ukraine sur le climat elle est elle
semble inaudible elle est inaudible
alors pas tellement dans les objectifs
puisque il y a l'Europe est extrêmement
ambitieuse moi 55% de diminution de nos
émissions au niveau en 2030 c'est très
ambitieux elle veut jouer un rôle je
crois que c'est important
du point de vue économique oubliant
appelé l'écologie deux minutes cette
transition écologique elle se fera on ne
peut pas accepter de ne pas aller vers
neutralité carbone l'inverse de
neutralité carbone c'est acceptée que
l'effet de serre augmente un définiment
est une certaine façon c'est
inacceptable en tout cas pour le
climatologue donc du point de vue
économique ce sont les je dirais entre
la Chine les États-Unis l'Europe et bien
c'est le bloc qui se mettra le premier à
dans cette transition qui gagnera
économiquement c'est ça qui est
important donc les le succès de
l'économie le dynamisme l'économie passe
par la transition on voit que le climat
était Cyril le disait absent des débats
ou quasiment absents est-ce qu'il y a
pas un problème d'incarnation autour de
la question de l'environnement on sait
que le passage au gouvernement de
Nicolas Hulot a été un échec qui
pourrait incarner la lutte pour le
climat est-ce qu'il faut que quelqu'un
qui l'incarne je ne sais pas donc on
aurait enfin il faudrait vraiment que on
voit bien bon si on revient Nicolas
Hulot disons le à chaque fois qu'il
allait en interministériel c'est être
disons les propositions du ministère de
l'écologie sont généralement laminées
soyons clairs donc c'est dans cet
équilibre des gouvernements voilà donc
vraiment un véritable ministre très
large sur finalement le mode de
développement de notre de notre société
c'est pas que l'écologie mais voilà
comment on fait pour que l'économie la
soit aussi au rendez-vous disons le
développement économique l'innovation
mais dans un esprit qui s'inscrit dans
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique et l'adaptation Cyril Viguier
faisait tout à l'heure référence au
climato-sceptique qu'avez-vous à leur
dire envie de leur dire aujourd'hui
d'abord
ce que je dis au climato-sceptique c'est
d'abord que le scepticisme lui-même est
quelque chose d'extrêmement légitime
c'est à dire que c'est normal que par
rapport à notre communauté effectivement
si vous acceptez l'idée que le
réchauffement climatique est une réalité
liée aux activités humaines ça devrait
normalement nous engager à l'action donc
important pour le développement de notre
mode de fonctionnement notre société
donc c'est normal qu'il y a scepticisme
mais il faut un moment regarder aussi
les arguments des uns et des autres et
là c'est très clair le réchauffement
climatique est lié aux activités
humaines et plus on va émettre de gaz à
effet de serre plus on va garder
l'échauffement important je l'affirme et
nous avons les arguments donc en
discuter n'est absolument pas et tout à
fait souhaitable y compris disons à
partir à convaincre les gens de cette
réalité mais nous avons vraiment les
arguments pour le démontrer et pour dire
nos craintes par rapport à un futur qui
ne serait pas sobre en carbone à la Une
de Nice Matin de nikaro la Une de
Nice-Matin la chute des oligarques la
pressions ce qui s'accentue sur ces
milliards 24
des hélicoptères et la plupart des des
avoir gelés sont sur la Côte d'Azur
justement ces schémas économiques Jean
Josel l'organisation de l'imposition ne
vont-ils pas complètement à
contre-courant des politiques
favorable à ce que vous préconisez oui
je pense que bon un des premiers risques
du réchauffement climatique c'est
l'accroissement des inégalités quand on
parle des oligarques comme plus en
parler de Nice c'est vraiment disons une
expression des inégalités sur cette
planète et on voit bien que il faut
solidarité
limitation des inégalités c'est plus une
génération enfin je crois qu'une société
plus juste ce sera plus encline enclin à
une lutte efficace contre le
réchauffement climatique ces gens je
vous aime le climatologue qui est notre
invité aujourd'hui dans face au
territoire merci de nicaro dans un
instant Armel Le Goff de 20 minutes sur
ce plateau
[Musique]
bonjour Armel Le Goff vous êtes la
directrice de la rédaction de 20 minutes
dans un instant on vient à notre invité
Jean jauzel mais nous partons pour
Fort-de-France en Martinique ou le
directeur éditorial de notre partenaire
France-Antilles à une question à vous
poser sur la montée des eaux l'écoute
bonjour
les effets du réchauffement climatique
se font sentir dans les territoires
d'outre-mer notamment ici aux Antilles
en Guyane avec la montée des eaux et la
mer qui grignote petit à petit un
certain nombre de zones du littoral
cette avancée de la mer sur sur les
terres est-elle inexorable où il y
a-t-il encore possibilité d'agir et de
faire quelque chose pour prévenir cette
montée des eaux donc oui elle est
inexorable je veux dire elle est
inexorable cette élévation du niveau de
la mer mais elle sera d'autant plus
limitée que nous limitons nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre si nous
réussissons à rester entre ça deux
degrés d'ici 2100 et au-delà et bien
elle sera limitée à 50 cm
supplémentaires d'ici la fin du siècle
mais 50 cm supplémentaires non le
problème c'est pour la presse
c'est-à-dire que ce qui est ce qui est
déjà en route c'est la une élévation du
niveau de la mer supplémentaire au cours
du prochain siècle des prochains siècles
c'est ça aussi le vrai problème donc il
faut dans aux investissements dans nos
constructions évidemment être insensif à
ça alors effectivement on peut s'adapter
il y a aussi la nécessité de s'adapter
avec le GIEC c'est de faire de la nature
notre allié est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer en quoi ça consiste par
exemple à l'élévation du niveau de la
mer quelquefois et bien il faut jouer
avec la nature disons sans faire une
alliée par exemple quand on regarde et
bien certaines digues bon je sais pas
j'ai évoqué le cas de Saint-Louis du
Sénégal récemment on fait une digue mais
disons que les problèmes se déplacent à
quelques kilomètres donc c'est pas ce
qu'il faut faire il faut bien réfléchir
à ce qu'on fait disons au contraire
l'adaptation peut profiter de disons par
exemple en replantant des mangroves dans
les régions disons vraiment vulnérable
en se faisant une alliée de la nature
effectivement donc il y a des choses à
faire plutôt que de disons en renforçant
de façon naturelle la capacité des par
exemple de limiter l'érosion et ça c'est
important c'est un peu c'est un message
très fort du dernier rapport du gel vous
avez raison par rapport à l'élévation du
nouveau le maire plutôt qu'une force
brute de faire des digues alors je ne
dis pas qu'il faut pas en faire mais il
faut vraiment réfléchir et allier disons
intégrer ces solutions
dans les vous dites aussi que certaines
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
sont imprévisibles notamment les
phénomènes type El Niño etc est-ce que
vous pouvez nous détailler ce que ça
veut dire oui disons dans la région
tropicale équatoriale ce qui est assez
fondamental c'est le rythme de ninio
c'est à dire que dans une année sur
trois sur quatre nous avons l'océan
Pacifique qui est beaucoup plus chaud
que notablement plus chaud que le sa
valeur moyenne ça a des conséquences sur
toute la ceinture tropicale et
équatoriale et on ne sait pas par
exemple vraiment prédire dans un monde
plus chaud la façon dont évoluer ces
phénomènes en ligne aussi vont être plus
fréquents plus intenses alors certains
scientifiques le pensent d'autres sont
plus réservés par rapport à donc c'est
important pour les régions tropicales
équatoriales
notre capacité à disons mieux anticiper
ces phénomènes elninaux et je reviens
sur les conséquences en France la France
ne serait épargnée par ce type de
phénomène concrètement ce serait surtout
le niveau d'élévation des mers qui se
répondent oui disons que la France on
est loin des disons de ces régions
tropicales et équatoriales en France
métropolitaine bien sûr et on parle un
petit peu ce qu'on appelle de
médicaments de
cyclones en Méditerranée mais c'est
quand même loin de nous non le vrai
problème c'est l'élévation du niveau de
la mer ce sont les sécheresses à
répétition les fuites anciennes par
contre on voit bien les vagues de
chaleur on se rend compte depuis des
virus oui bien sûr donc les conséquences
sur la nature sur la santé sur la
biodiversité
de covid oui c'est à dire que ça disons
il y a un lien entre la capacité de
certains virus ou de certaines maladies
disons vectorielles à se disséminer plus
rapidement dans un climat plus chaud
effectivement des habitats qui n'étaient
pas
elle se disséminine aussi parce que on
prend de plus beaucoup plus de place sur
la nature et qu'on investit des zones où
on est en contact potentiellement avec
des virus
entre la mondialisation qui fait que
tout le monde vibre nous-mêmes
probablement d'un endroit à l'autre de
la planète et transporte aussi des ans
c'est un risque bien sûr c'était
beaucoup plus lent disons au 15e siècle
disons la
dissémination de ces simplement de ces
virus parce que il y avait moins de
mouvements de population mais ça joue
mais c'est effectivement
accéléré ça peut être accéléré par le
réchauffement climatique mais c'est bien
au départ notre soif de déplacement de
bougeotte sur la planète qui est
peut-être à l'origine aussi de de ces de
ces disséminations autre phénomène que
vous pointez comme un risque lié au
réchauffement climatique c'est
l'aggravation des inégalités
potentiellement nos sociétés pourraient
être plus injustes en cas de
réchauffement important et de
conséquences sur sur nos vies oui je
vais citer je vais citer deux exemples
dans prenons par exemple dans
ces vagues de chaleur s'épile de chaleur
l'été donc je nous vivons à Paris enfin
une partie de l'année bon quand il y a
une vague de chaleur à Paris et bien on
a la chance de pouvoir aller en Bretagne
il y a ceux qui peuvent disons je crois
que beaucoup de parisiens ou de la
banlieue parisienne et dans d'autres
métropole au moment des pics de chaleur
souhaiteraient quitter l'appartement où
ils sont il y a ceux qui le peuvent ceux
qui ne peuvent pas un autre exemple et
bien la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique l'augmentation de la taxe
carbone telle qu'elle était envisagée il
y a 4 ans et bien aurait affecté de
façon relative trois fois plus les bas
revenus que les hauts revenus avec des
paradoxes incroyables quand on climatise
chez soi on ne contribue pas évidemment
à ne pas la bonne solution c'est un des
problèmes de cette année problème de
l'isolation et de des bâtiments en
France comment assure-t-on le confort
d'été on porte pas assez de regard en
France sur le confort des personnes n'en
parle dans la sphère politique oui
effectivement nous en avions parlé dans
le Grenelle de l'environnement j'étais
vous appliquer ça m'avait marqué que on
n'était pas assez attentif au confort
d'été à disons avoir des appartements
qui restent agréables étaient sans
forcément avoir de la climatisation mais
Le Goff il y a ce sujet qui est dans la
loi climat et résilience qui était aussi
dans la convention citoyenne pour le
climat des échos contributions justement
qui pour compenser le fait que nos vies
sont gourmandes en
carbone c'est quand même compliqué pour
les politiques d'appliquer ces éco
contributions on l'a vu avec le
mouvement des gilets jaunes oui oui on
voit bien face ça dépend ça dépend
lesquels donc je dirais que c'est
toujours extrêmement difficile ça disons
bien sûr on peut revenir à Ségolène
Royal et l'écologie punitive mais il
faut aussi il faut aussi des signaux il
faut aussi dire disons à toutes les
couches de la population que chacun peut
faire quelque chose c'est ça qui est
important donc
engagez-vous c'est pour ça que j'aimais
d'ailleurs une
j'ai toujours été assez favorable à une
mesure comme la limitation de de la
vitesse à 110 km/h sur l'autoroute pense
que ça touche tout le monde il y a le
symbole aussi effectivement tout le
monde est à égalité donc tout le monde
se mobilise voilà la Une de 20 minutes
d'hier la Une de 20 minutes c'est sur le
front républicain puisque il y a des
incertitudes sur le report des voix
notamment de des électeurs de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et puis je rappelle une
édition numérique de 20 minutes un
magazine sur la blockchain oui tout à
fait la métaverse ce qui va se passer
dans le monde futur elle sera pas
concernée par l'écologie environnement
climatique on sera dans le monde
numérique oui mais c'est un des
problèmes du monde numérique c'est que
il contribue aussi de façon accélérée
d'ailleurs
les choses dans lesquelles j'ai investi
récemment c'est plus dans le biochard
qui est une possibilité de stocker du
carbone dans les sols voilà donc
j'investis mais pas bon voilà maintenant
je ne suis pas tellement je ne suis pas
tellement tourné vers ces ils ont ce
futur ce futur virtuel où et ça ne
m'attire pas trop effectivement je dois
dire ces gens jouaient le climatologue
ex vice-président du vieux qui est notre
invité on continue dans un instant
d'émettre korkmas de T5 non merci
Armelle Le Goff merci Armel
[Musique]
bonjour des mecs dans un instant nous
allons interviewer Jean nous allons
ensemble notre partenaire Centre France
la montagne depuis Clermont-Ferrand
Jean-Jaurès Nicolas faucon qui est
journaliste à la montagne a une question
à vous poser la guerre ces conséquences
en l'écoute
je vous ai le bonjour la guerre en
Ukraine a mis en évidence notre
dépendance au gaz russe et aux énergies
fossiles ainsi que la nécessité de
tendre vers l'autonomie énergétique si
cette guerre éclipse le sujet du
réchauffement climatique peut-elle
constituer un levier pour accélérer la
lutte contre le dérèglement alors que le
GIEC dans son dernier rapport pointe
l'urgence à agir il nous reste que trois
ans pour lutter contre les effets les
plus dévastateurs alors bonjour Nicolas
faucon oui alors est-ce que est-ce qu'il
faut disons j'aurais aimé que
effectivement cette guerre soit aussi la
prise de conscience de la nécessité
d'une autonomie est énergétique dans
notre pays au niveau de l'Europe et si
possible ça aura en carbone avec je le
crois franchement et c'est ce que nous
dit le rapport RTE laissez une très
grande place au développement des
énergies renouvelables qui ne se
développent pas au rythme souhaitable
c'est très clair après il y a un débat
sur le nucléaire mais qui est peut-être
de second plan mais il faut vraiment il
faut vraiment aller de l'avant et je
pense que mon regret par exemple et bien
c'est que la première annonce c'est la
réouverture de disons d'une centrale à
charbon à Saint-Avold donc ça va contre
sens ça je veux dire oui c'est ce qu'il
faudrait mais la réalité ce n'est pas ce
qui se passe sous nos yeux actuellement
y compris dans notre pays les maîtres
mats le GIEC a rendu son rapport avec 48
heures de retard visiblement les experts
ont dû batailler pour formuler des
solutions est-ce que le GIEC est aussi
soumis à des vents contraires c'est pas
ça mais bon moi je trouve ça terrible
c'est qu'on s'est disons c'est
s'adoptions par vidéo les gens peuvent
rester jusqu'au dernier moment ce qui se
passe dans une enfin moi j'ai vécu une
vingtaine d'adoptions des rapports du
siècle alors généralement ça se termine
théoriquement le vendredi soir jamais à
partir du samedi matin les gens du
samedi midi samedi après-midi les gens
ont des avions à prendre donc ils
partent donc ça se termine mais là par
contre comme c'est en vidéo les gens
oui oui je n'ai pas où on va mais voilà
mais je veux dire par là que là elle
s'est faite en vidéo derrière l'écran et
les gens sont restés accrochés jusqu'à
la fin il y a aussi une part de jeu
c'est lié un peu à cela mais là en
l'occurrence il y a des pays qui ont
vraiment poussé pour que alors
évidemment ils ont tous des intérêts
contraires et donc chacun a poussé pour
que
sa formulation soit retenue au détriment
d'une autre il y a eu plus de défiance
aussi entre les pays du Nord et les pays
du Sud oui disons que depuis alors on
parle pas du GIEC mais de Glasgow de la
conférence climat le fait que le fait
que les pays développés soient
incapables de tenir leurs promesses de
mettre à disposition des pays en voie
développement 100 milliards de dollars
chaque année pour les aider à lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique et
c'est adapté nous n'avons pas été
capable de disons de tenir cette
promesse c'est suffisant du reste non
c'est pas suffisant il faudrait plutôt
le double d'ici 2025 mais déjà le fait à
une époque où les pays développés nous
avons investi
que d'autres pays mais si nous n'y
allons pas tous ensemble c'est bien ça
le problème et d'ailleurs l'Arabie
saoudite a affiché neutralité carbone
horizon 2060 si nous n'allons pas tous
ensemble nous ne réussirons pas et que
dire de la position indienne par exemple
sur le droit au développement oui c'est
là aussi c'est on peut affirmer un droit
au développement ça semble tellement
naturel c'est vrai pour l'Afrique c'est
vrai pour justement pour l'un de pour
tous les pays je dirais en développement
et la seule façon affirmer ce droit à
quelque chose mais c'est à nous aussi
pays développé d'aider ces pays à se
développer mais tout en adoptant une
stratégie bas carbone c'est cela le
disant comment réussit à ton à aider au
développement des pays en votre
développement et quand même à les mettre
sur des bonnes trajectoires en termes
d'émission est-ce que la solution peut
venir par exemple des géants du Net par
exemple est-ce que les gafams sont des
alliés ou plutôt des ennemis donc les
bons je dirais que les Gafa sont des
alliés s'ils effectivement contribués
par exemple le développement des
énergies renouvelables on peut regarder
avoir c'est pas un gafam et Tesla par
exemple un joueur rôle important joue un
rôle important dans le développement du
véhicule électrique donc il y a aussi
beaucoup de développement technologiques
les Gafa peuvent contribuer à faire pas
dans le domaine vraiment du numérique je
ne crois pas que le numérique lui-même
soit la solution par lui-même disons ça
peut y contribuer mais il faut un esprit
de sobriété que les Gafa n'ont pas
vraiment et qu'il ne nous indiquent pas
je prends le cas de la 5G si on met la
5G à disposition de chacun d'entre nous
pour faire du streaming c'est un échec
en termes de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique deux fois plus
d'émissions les numériques c'est deux
fois plus d'émissions que l'aérien par
exemple on parle beaucoup d'aériens mais
pas du tout du numérique justement Jean
Josel la Cour des comptes européennes en
2017 a publié un rapport qui estime à
1115 milliards d'euros le montant total
nécessaire à investir durant 10 ans pour
atteindre les objectifs de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre cela
fait énormément de quoi qu'il en coûte
non
non c'est disons c'est d'ailleurs le
chiffre que nous avions repris alors
d'ailleurs dans une dans une triste
donc ce sont des investissements nous on
avait pris qu'ils ont on a mis 1000
milliards avec Pierre la route ou dans
une tribune dans westfrance il y a moins
5 6 ans on a mis 8 milliards pour sauver
les banques on peut disons mettre 1000
milliards pour pour effectivement sauver
le climat on a bien trouvé effectivement
l'argent pour sauver les banques sans
aucun problème mais pour trop bon je ne
vois pas ce sont des investissements et
donc on pourrait effectivement aller de
l'avant avec ses investissements et
créer un nouveau dynamisme la transition
c'est aussi synonyme de dynamisme
économique d'inventivité mais il faut
que cette inventivité soit évaluée par
rapport à sa capacité à s'inscrire dans
cette neutralité carbone ça fait bientôt
40 minutes qu'on vous écoute en direct
sur TV5 Monde j'ai une question un peu
personnelle à vous poser voyons tout ça
analysant tout ça regardons tout ça
est-ce que vous croyez en Dieu je vous
aime ah oui alors moi ce que je crois en
Dieu oui effectivement je suis de
tradition catholique disons très très je
reste je continue à aller disons disons
à la messe de temps en temps mais
effectivement cette affaire non j'ai une
certaine spiritualité d'ailleurs bon
mais je pense que en tout cas tout ce
qui aide tout ce qui est à la solidarité
peut aider dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique c'est bien
apprécié si on parle effectivement non
pas de Dieu mais du pape je dirais la
lancylique l'audat aussi était vraiment
très riche donc on peut aussi à travers
des engagements disons disons plus
petites religieux spirituel contribuer
parce que c'est la solidarité qui est au
rendez-vous contribué à une certaine
façon à la paix dans le monde et je
crois quand même à la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique pour vous aider
est-ce qu'il y a une adresse est-ce
qu'il y a quelque chose à faire 30
secondes alors pour pour alors pour nous
aider oui moi mon regret alors je me
tourne plutôt vers les politiques là
parce que quand même la recherche ce qui
est absent ce qui est absent de de
ils ont le réchauffement climatique est
absent mais pas la recherche est encore
plus absente et je demande vraiment au
décideurs politiques d'avoir un regard
vers la recherche quels qu'ils soient un
soutien à la recherche au sens large et
très important merci infiniment Jean
merci
en direct climatologue ex vice-président
du GIEC je rappelle votre livre climat
parlons vrai Jean Jaurès et Baptiste
Dely merci à tous on se retrouve jeudi
prochain bien sûr et les programmes
continuent sur TV 5 monde au revoir des
maths merci beaucoup au revoir merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]